on today's show we talked to a mom who's
struggling with remote learning
and her teenage son we also talked to a
great mom whose 17 year old son is about
to become
a dad and she wants to know if she can
love her new grandbaby
we also talk to an awesome son whose
mom's a hoarder and he doesn't know what
to do
stay tuned
[Applause]
hey what is up everybody how are we
doing i hope everybody's doing well
loving life being kind to one another
enjoying their families enjoying their
friends and if you're sitting at home by
yourself
if you're sitting at home by yourself
just listening to a podcast
you might be a serial killer hopefully
you're out walking in the neighborhood
or something
kelly just cheered she's like i love
serial killer she doesn't she loves
serial killer podcast um okay so
on today's show we got a lot going on
um first and foremost we're glad you're
here
on this show we talk about relationships
mental health wellness all those things
give us a shout at uh 844-693-3291
that's 1-844-693-3291
and i'm having a moment of conscious
here
and a conscious is that how you say
consciousness
conscience there was no vocabulary
section in grad school for me
um i'm having a moment of conscience so
i've got to pay up
as you remember we had a big football
game i don't know it was a month or two
ago now
a big football game between the goat
the 88 year old quarterback in tampa bay
and as a former texas tech guy patrick
mahomes
and if it's just disturbing how guys
like grown men like me claim college
kids
as ours and then we follow them through
their professional career
and we chain our uh
self-esteem to them but that's what i
did i love patrick mahomes as
as a as a student and as a student
athlete and then he went on to
become the chiefs quarterback and
clearly they were going to dominate
the tampa bay buccaneers
we have a engineer back here engineers
are the guys that make all this happen
and um kyle should call the show every
once in a while because he's psychotic
and he's got some challenges in his
heart and soul and he is a die hard he
has worn a tampa bay buccaneers shirt
every day
since the super bowl except for a few
days when he wore
the tampa bay like devil raised shirts
right
but here's the thing i bet kyle some
money
i lost i need him to pay up on camera
so here you go kyle i am i am paying you
20 bucks that i owe you because your
your old man beat my young kid man
a month later listen we don't all make
the money that engineers make it took me
a while to save up that 20 bucks
i appreciate you being grateful and not
charging me interest
oh that's hard for me to do guys tom
brady at some point
do you want to do a debt-free stream
i'm dead i'm debt-free yeah way to go
kyle
that's actually pretty funny way to go
man that's why you don't bet engineers
they always they're always right they
always are right cannot believe
tampa bay one hey at some point you just
have to tip your hat to
tom brady he's just better he's just
he's magic he's got something man
what a stud that's awesome so i am debt
free i no longer owe this engineer money
and now my soul feels lighter and free
that's awesome all right so
we have a packed show today so let's get
right to the phones
let's go to lisa in charlottesville
virginia lisa what's going on good
morning how can i help
good morning john how are you i'm good
how's everything
it's good doing good waiting for
springtime yes ma'am
all right so what's going on how can i
help so i have a 16 year old son
who is doing his schooling virtual
at home right now they actually had the
option to go back two days a week
but i wasn't quite sure how the
protocols were going to be you know of
course they tell you how it's going to
be but
you know until you experience yourself
so i just went ahead and kept him home
he's doing
really good in most of his classes
but there's always one class each
semester that he's fallen behind in
and he claims that he's just it
he's bored with it it doesn't interest
him
and i'm just wondering if maybe if he
were actually in class
and having to see that teacher face to
face
if that would have potentially
made it better for him so i'm just just
kind of wondering if i made the right
decision they're not sending them back
um or if there's some other things i
could do to help them
he's really into video games so he he
wants to actually be a video game
program or create video games
when he gets older so you know the
pre-calc that he's failing right now
just doesn't interest him
oh so he's struggling with pre-cal he
is um he's a sophomore in high school
he's um
he's a sophomore in pre-cal yeah
ever since elementary school you know
he's been he's been ahead he's been in
honors classes or
been taking high school classes in uh
middle school so
he has the potential it's just the want
yeah
um so are you not sending him back
because
of your concern about his health
um he actually you know i i talk with
him about it i don't just
make the decision i also include what
what he feels because you know in this
uncertain time with the virus
you know i would feel terrible if i sent
him to school and then he got sick
so we we did discuss it we did discuss
it and he said well
i think until we get you know a vaccine
because you know the teachers at that
time hadn't been vaccinated
uh vaccinated as well they have been now
um but of course he can't go in in the
middle of the semester and change it up
to
uh partially virtual oh so he couldn't
go now he couldn't
if you decided i'm gonna send him in he
couldn't go i don't know
i would have to look into it i don't
think so but you know
i can certainly look into that so i'll
give you
i'm going to tell you not a medical
answer i'm going to tell you what i've
done in my own house
and then give you some some broader
context okay
and then interestingly i struggled with
one class in high school
and that was pre-cal and it was
a and i i'm now i'm old and i've got two
phds right so it's not an indicator of
how dumb somebody is as you mentioned
it's
it was a hundred percent want to um some
of it was foundational
i had skated through my early math
classes and i hadn't really spent the
time learning
the the constructs there because i could
get by on the tests right
and some students who can test well or
can float through some of those things
end up missing some of those
foundational
concepts and then pre-cal man it it
separates the the sheep from the goats
right and if you don't have a history of
algebra you don't have a history
of some of those that linear thinking
man it can be really challenging
it was a hundred percent want to in my
case right
right and what ultimately got me around
the bin was i couldn't play
if i couldn't pass and you're talking
about it i never
i didn't get seized the first c i ever
got was in
precal and it was the war of 1812 in my
house when that happened and so
the other thing is is i my wife and i
man we are as cautious as can be and um
i've stayed on top of the data as much
as i could the decision we made in our
house
was the pros far outweighed the cons
about keeping the kids out of school so
i actually put both
kids are back in school and um we're
we're a cautious family
we just are some of our friends think
we're comically too cautious
um but the benefits of the
the science on the kids being out of
school just hasn't been backed up by the
data
so um if there's a chance i i won't tell
you what to do i'm gonna tell you what
we did in our house okay
when it comes to um
that that messy situation that you're in
which is you got a kid that clearly has
the academic capability right he can do
it
and he's got that things that he loves
to do
and then when he loves when he gets
lasered in he can knock him out of the
park right
and he really has something that he
loves which is video games
and he has something that he thinks he
wants to do someday which would be a
video game programmer
and then he sloughs off one class those
to me are actually easier to deal with
because you're not dealing with
a a capability issue it's just
a want to and that's when mom and
dad and child can have some pretty
simple
consequence and um decision consequence
actions or conversations right
so right you get your you get your
precal done
which means you have to put extra time
in and then you get this video game box
and if you don't you don't it's pretty
simple and what i
love to do with young people is make
sure they understand
a hundred percent of this is their
choice
they get to choose in or they get to
choose out
right that's it it's simple and if you
want to
choose to have access to this video game
thing then you're going to
choose to knock this stuff out of the
park and then
it they just get to own that and they
more importantly they get to own the
consequences of it right
the one thing i want to make sure you do
is don't weaponize connection
the other thing i want to make sure you
do is
covid does not mean no boundaries
all these kids are so exhausted and they
are fried and they are
have had to create alternative ways of
living
right and so as a parent i've found
myself
just being like ah it doesn't matter ah
it doesn't matter and it super does
because
when the boundaries at home start
falling apart too and then it becomes
ahead to stay up whatever do whatever
you need to do it's just this one class
they are begging for some semblance of
normalcy some
semblance of boundary and that falls on
us as the parents right
so when you tell this really smart
bright
good young man of yours hey you gotta do
you gotta pick it up in precal what's
the response what does he say
well many times he will say that he
didn't see the assignment
um which you know that's inaccurate
right
yeah well and and i mean i can
understand because they have so many
different
uh platforms that they get this
information from
but if i can access it i know he can
well and he's
he's a gamer he can see somebody in call
of duty shooting him
from eight screens over upside down
right
he can get that info right yeah it's
it's definitely a want
a yeah um you know
i i i'm i'm like you i think you know
being being back in school right now for
kids
is the best thing as long as it's safe
that's right
and i think if if he had to
face his teacher rather than facing me
with an
answer i think he would step it up a bit
well and if you're not able to if you
all choose to not put him back in school
if you're
if you're unable to put him back in
midstream
i think that i want him to have that
same relational connectivity with you
right and so it's important for parents
to never weaponize that connection
right you're not going to take away your
morning breakfast with him you're not
going to take away
time you all spend together he just
loses something of of significant value
he's got to feel that pressure
right he's got to feel that boundary
that he chooses
right and so if you choose to not go
find this assignment and make sure you
are a hundred percent
caught up and not only 100 caught up but
you're doing the work
then you are choosing directly not even
as a byproduct you are directly choosing
you're telling us as a family unit i
don't want to play video games
i don't want to be connected with my
friends through technology in these ways
right that's cool you're choosing to
hang out with mom and dad and do puzzles
tonight because also you can't just go
plug
hole up in your room either you are
choosing to
um have a lip sync competition with me
and your other brothers and sisters and
your dad in the living room instead of
playing video games
we love that you made this choice it
probably would have been a lot better
for your heart and soul to have done
your precal homework because now we're
gonna record this uh
lip sync contest whatever whatever the
thing is right so
your job is to help him be encouraged
and to set up those boundaries firm and
strong
and his job is to make sure that he
lives into those boundaries and
that he understands choice he
understands consequence
and then he gets to make his deal right
if he chooses to fail
man that's going to be really hard
because there's going to be some really
strong consequences there
if he chooses to disrespect his teacher
in his class by
not going to check out what the
communication is man that's hard
if he can get back in class and y'all
think that's a good idea for your family
awesome i think that's great but at the
end of the day he can choose to fail all
high school kids can
and it must cost him dearly right and
this is going to be hard because it
falls
on you it falls on me it falls on us
parents
and wow this has been a season a hard
season of trying to find the right thing
to do
right so i appreciate your heart for
whatever it's worth
if he doesn't like pre-cal and he
struggles with it and it beats him
upside the head a little bit and he has
to learn some hard lessons
he can still be successful you're
looking at a guy that had that exact
same trajectory so
good for you for caring about him lisa
i'm grateful that you're out there in
the world and in the community loving
your kid the way you are
and um tell him to give me a call i'd
love to talk to him just see how he's
doing
and i haven't had any high school kids
on the show yet so tell him to give me a
shout and we'll talk about pre-cal
i'm not going to be able to help him
with it but we can talk about it that'd
be great all right let's go to kelly in
kansas city missouri
kelly what's going on how's it how's it
happening hi dr d
thanks for taking my call thank you for
calling
thank you i have a 17 year old son
and he and his 16 year old girlfriend
are expecting a baby at the end of next
month
oh wow so it's right here huh
yes it is
yes it is i'm just trying to figure out
how to parent through this
i've not been doing a great job and
it's going to be here real soon so how
do
i help support these kids to the best of
my ability
i love that you asked that question and
that you're vulnerable
i really do thank you for
making this phone call and for whatever
it's worth
if i look at the data there's several
hundred thousand parents across the
country this year
they're going to be in your same
situation and so
you're helping out a lot of other people
too so thank you for making that call
so when you say you haven't been doing a
good job what does that mean
well i'm just so confused as if i should
be
happy and excited and talking to these
kids like
in an exciting way or just trying to
prep them
and i know that they're getting a lot of
information just trying to prep them
steer them make sure that they're doing
well in school
when doing what they need to do and um
but then there's you know it's like
am i should i be excited or should i be
you know pounding on them and just
making sure they're doing what they need
to do
to graduate school i mean they're both
juniors and they still have one more
year of high school
so they're going to be living with one
of us
um my son's dad and i are divorced and
then
the girls parents are still together but
it's like
maybe staying and how how do we do this
i love it okay so couple things are they
so they are gonna
continue uh some sort of romantic
relationship together and raise this
baby that's the goal
yes that is the goal okay and they're
going to
move in with either you or
ex-husband or her parents
um we're not sure right now it sounds
like we're on a rotation
since my son goes back and forth between
his dad and myself yet
but i don't know that that's the
healthiest right it's not yeah yeah
okay okay so are you have you sat down
and
had some sort of conversation some sort
of
connection with her parents
a little bit um mainly her mom
her dad's an alcoholic and um
but her mom seems super giddy very
excited
that she also is drowning in her own
problems
yep okay are they cool with her
their daughter and their new grandbaby
moving in with you guys
i don't know that okay um
we have not really had that discussion
okay so
and i don't know that she really could
move in
to either my home or my ex-husbands
i mean i probably have the most space
but at the same time
i have a lot of pets and the girl is
allergic to
a lot of things okay so so here's what
here's i'm gonna give you a whole bunch
of stuff okay and if it gets too much to
write down
in fact i'll say don't write this down
you can circle back whenever this
um episode airs and then you can
pass it along to everybody involved here
and
this will give you some hey
this guy on the radio recommended that
we do some of these things together
and i want to follow that lead right so
i'm going to give you a
a a tip of spear here like a
a way to engage in these conversations
that might otherwise be a little bit
messy
but your your son and your new grandbaby
and your i don't even know what you
would call her
the the mother of your grandbaby right
because it's not going to be your
you know your daughter-in-law anything
yet um they need
an adult to step up and help guide
what's coming
okay so to answer your original question
yes be as excited
and cheer this is a baby
i don't want your son welcoming in
a human being under a cloud of
negativity and regret
and they will need somebody to cheerlead
them to teach them how wonderful and
exciting and beautiful this new human
being is going to
and they need somebody to help guide
them
on i mean the government just said a
year ago you can drive
right so there's still kids they're
still children
they need somebody else to help guide
them on
the responsibilities that they have no
idea
are coming their way right so it's a
both
and but if you lean too heavy on
the fire and the brimstone
and the everything in this moment that
sounds so cliche is led by love
love love smiles you are gonna have to
let go of this fantasy it's gone right
your life took a left turn you didn't
expect it wasn't how you would have
drawn it up but it is what it is
now you gotta choose i'm gonna love this
grandbaby until
i'm gonna love this little baby like
she's never been loved before
and i'm gonna model for my son and his
girlfriend
what this kind of love looks like right
um everybody's got to be involved in
that way
if that grand baby goes to one of these
homes and
is is bathed in shame
bathed and we you shouldn't be here my
your daddy screwed up
man you were talking about legacy
changing shame you're talking about
family tree altering um
self-hatred and that baby doesn't
deserve that okay
so everybody's got to be on the same
page
as much as possible this is going to
mean that somebody and i'm
you called so i'm i'm appointing you
somebody's got to call a meeting
with the parents of these kids that
means you might have to get back in the
same room as your ex-husband or at least
get on a zoom call
that means her mom if dad's not
functioning then her mom's going to come
over
and you all need to come up with a game
plan and i'd recommend
six months to a year and then we're
going to reevaluate
at i i hate to tell you this your pets
come a distant distant distant
third number one to grandbaby number two
to your own kids
number three animals okay and if yours
is the only place these children can
help can be together
and they're not going to be in the home
of an unsafe alcoholic and they're not
going to be in the home of
your ex-husband who for whatever reason
can't do it then that means you're going
to have to make some hard hard decisions
and you're going to have to make some
hard decisions not to regret not to
resent and not to get into that that
loathing cycle man
this is all for this little baby okay
all the focus here
is on the future so you're gonna have to
help your son stay involved with this
child gonna teach him how to be involved
he's gonna have to grow up real quick
and he also is gonna have to have
connection with other people
right and finding that balance is gonna
be so tough
you didn't sign up for this but it is in
your lap right
and my guess is just how you just
explained the
her parents and your ex-husband this is
gonna disproportionately fall on you
so you're gonna have to be extra
intentional about self-care for yourself
whether you need to get a counselor
whether you need to get some friends in
your life that can help
if you gotta recruit some of your
buddies from
you know your local group or a local
church or whatever that can
be on babysitting duty because you need
a break too this is gonna fall on you
and what's gonna happen is you're gonna
start hating ex-husband even more you're
gonna start getting frustrated at her
parents you're gonna start poking and
crying
and then suddenly the the the human
being that gets sacrificed at the edge
of that resentment is this little baby
okay
all right so you gotta do whatever it
takes
to help your son and this young lady
graduate high school
because now you're playing a statistics
game and that is
if they don't graduate high school
there's a pretty clear trajectory
unless they become that one and a 5
billion person
right um those things are going to be
really tough on them they got to go to
high school
and then they either have to go find a
local college that's close they can
continue this
or they're going to have to find a local
trade or whatever but the goal is
they've got to continue
and finish this education um it doesn't
mean that their future is over it means
it's going to be way more challenging
out of the gate
and um getting everybody together
making a plan for six months and we're
gonna revisit then the next six months
and we're going to revisit
um and then the next six months we're
going to revisit and we'll just have to
take it a semester at a time or a year
at a time a year for a 17 year old is a
thousand years right you remember those
days right
yes um so i'll tell you something that
happened when i was a
uh dean of students at a university had
a young woman come in
and she was pregnant was not part of the
plan
she was a young college student she came
in with her head held down
and she walked into our dean of students
office she was trying to figure out how
to take a leave of absence what she
could do
because and she just had this demeanor
about her
that she was defeated and i stepped i
heard her talking to the admin i stepped
out and said hey come in my office
and she i said what's going on she said
well i'm pregnant and i cheered
i said you're gonna have a baby and she
looked at me and got wide-eyed
and i said no you didn't this isn't the
way you drew it up
but you're gonna have a baby and i i at
the time had a two-year-old i think or a
one-year-old three-year-old something
like that
and i just talked to her for a second
about this is the messiest
craziest most bananas adventure and i've
never
known love like i know right now with my
little bitty girl
and she just started crying and she said
something that was heavy she said
you're the first person to talk about my
baby
as as somebody to be loved her mom
called me later that night
earlier that evening and said i want to
thank you
for for challenging me like that
because nobody everybody has met my
daughter's eyes with
how could you i can't believe you oh my
you did what
your life's over you're this and her mom
just said man i'd fallen into that trap
and so
thank you for reminding me i'm about to
have a grandkid right
is this gonna be so hard yes did you
want your son to grow up and go to
college and be in a fraternity yes and
be all
silly and be goofy and then you meet
that
your grandkid when he's 27 yeah that's
how you drew it up and it's not gonna
happen that way
and so the quicker we can turn that dial
to laser in on
man we got to be real specific about
what life's gonna look like
real specific because you got kids
raising kid now
but also bathe everybody in love right
so when i say that how does that ring
true to you
it feels good you're validating that
it's okay to be happy
and excited about this i mean abortion
or adoption were never on the table and
so
um it feels good to know that i can
support them
and be happy about it so
thank you for that well i thank you for
your heart and
i think it could be a lot of fun this
might be cheesy but
it could be a lot of fun because now you
can give parenting classes
you can give diaper or whatever putting
on and changing
class whatever you get to do something
that
i can imagine many many moms across
history have wanted to do
which is your son still lives in your
house so you can teach him how to
love the mother of his baby and you
could teach him what getting up at 3am
to get a bottle looks like and you can
teach him what not going to the movies
looks like
and you could teach them how to do what
cleaning bottles with those little
bottle scrubbers that were made by satan
what that looks like right all that
stuff because he has to
because he still lives with you right
right and you get to teach him what
honoring grandma
looks like and you can teach him what
honoring that little baby looks like
man so there's is this a is this a mess
there's no question
and am i being pollyanna about it yes i
am i know it's in store for you for the
next three four five six years and it's
hard
hard hard hard and you're going to be a
grandma
right there's this little baby that's
going to be about to show up
and it's going to be a disaster
it is you know it is yes absolutely but
mine was a disaster not this bad of a
disaster but mine was a disaster right i
mean i don't know anybody who's like oh
this is just smooth sailing way to go
everybody
so yes this is about love
love your kids love her love this little
baby is it a girl or a boy
it's a girl oh my gosh you're gonna have
a granddaughter
right yes and you're gonna get in
spit spittle fights with her
this young woman's parents you and your
ex
you thought you and your ex-husband
fought oh man it's gonna be awesome
right right um but it's all for the sake
of
this little baby it's all for the sake
of this little baby
so get an architect man get up someone
who's going to help you map out what
this is going to look like
parenting classes every saturday for the
next the next two years right
high school class how can we get them
graduated quickly with them into a local
community college quick
you may have to tell some of your cats
and dogs and chickens and frogs and
birds or whatever you got in the house
they got to find new homes because my
granddaughter's moving in
my granddaughter's moving in right and
be the first to volunteer tell the other
parents involved
i'm going to let them live here that
baby is going to get to go see mom as
long as she's safe
in the home of an alcoholic we're going
to make sure everything everything's
safe
and then we're going to figure it out as
we go and make sure you take care of you
during this time because it's going to
be tough because you're going to be
carrying a lot of this load
i'm so grateful for you and for
every parent listening your kids will do
things
not as you drew them up they'll do
things not as you drew them up they will
they're gonna do stupid things they're
gonna do heartbreaking things you're
gonna do
mind-numbing things it's okay
to circle back to love every single
time every time every time all right
thank you so much kelly
all right so i brought some of these
with me
throwing a curveball here guys um let me
grab these
oh man all right so some
of the most common questions i get are
what are some of my favorite books what
am i reading what have i read recently
so i just grabbed a handful of these out
of my office and out of my
um the little place where i read at my
house and let you know a couple books
i'm going to show you here
a book probably my favorite book of 2020
2021 was johann hari's lost connections
this book
is incredible it's awesome um
it is a journalist who's goes on a
rabbit hole to try to figure out
if we've got all these solutions quote
unquote to depression and anxiety and
it's a disease
why can't we just solve it right like
strep throat we can take an antibiotic
and it goes away what's the deal
and man he pulls a ribbon on this this
was super annoying because this is the
book i was prepping to write and then he
does a way better job than i could ever
do so
johan hari check this book out um
this book is man i am late to the game
on this one i met james
at an event right before covid canceled
everything
he's a really remarkable guy very kind
very very intelligent
this book atomic habits is remarkable
it's simple
it's clear it's very humbly written he
does one of my favorite things that an
author can do which is tip his hat to
all the other people who've played a
role in
the the research on habits but this is
really good and it's sold millions and
millions
this will be one of those books that's
on the best seller list forever right
um if you are a little bit of a sciencey
nerd and you want to learn
about working with kids who have been
who've got challenges
judy cohen judith cohen is the guru on
trauma tfcbt trauma focus
cognitive behavioral therapy working
with children this book is heavy this
book is
a heavy not scientifically but heavy
it's a lot of hard dark stuff in it but
it's really really good
um this book is one i'm almost finished
with now it's by mark lewis
it's called the biology of desire why
addiction
is not a disease it is extraordinary
it's extraordinary it's a well-done book
um he peels back some myths again
we have taken all of our pathologies and
we have
all the things that we struggle with
depression anxiety addiction
and we've just labeled them all diseases
we've labeled them all diseases and
one by one medical researchers doctors
pedagogical experts learning experts are
saying ah
it's not a disease it's something way
bigger
and way deeper and more importantly
since it's not a disease that means we
can we can change we can grow
we can learn and we can begin to do new
things
and that's exciting and if you're a
counselor if you're interested in mental
health
this is the masterpiece by irving yolum
one most important guys
i had a chance to spend a minute with
him in san francisco a few years ago
he's like talking to yoda it's really
extraordinary but this is called the
gift of therapy it's a letter to
young therapists and it's extraordinary
and i just finished this book the other
day
um by thomas joyner thomas joyner is the
best
he is my favorite he's a suicide
researcher he's the top of the game out
of florida state
um this book is kind of all over the
place but it talks about
um it's called lonely at the top yeah
lonely at the top by
the the high cost of male success
there's a new perspective
on loneliness a new perspective on
what's going on culturally i imagine
it's controversial it's got some stuff
in it that i
raised my eyebrows and i was like man i
can't believe this got through the
publisher but i liked it it was a real
it's a new way of looking at problems
but it's stuff that i've been
researching and i experienced myself
which is
man when you make achievement when you
make chasing
money when you make chasing the next job
title next thing
your goal man
you just implode and he's got some stuff
in there that talks about the nexus of
there are no men run everything
and they have for a long long long time
and men lead the way in every
demonstrable disease
cancer heart attacks strokes
obesity they are diabetes so it's this
nexus of men
are in control and men are dying
right and what can we do about it how do
we back out of this thing what are some
things we can do
and he does not just say you know what
you need to do get a warm bath and a
candle
he gives some very practical advice and
so um check out any of those books
that's just where my head is at these
days
what i'm reading um and by the way i if
someone's like oh this book has really
i don't agree with anything i'll put
that right off my list
because i want to read stuff that's
going to challenge me that i'm going to
mark up and disagree with
and i love going to war with authors in
in a book so all right let's take one
more call before we wrap up the show
let's go to curtis
in anaheim curtis what's going on how
can i help
hey dr john thanks for taking my call to
pleasure to be able to speak with you
you too brother what's going on so uh
i my mom essentially is a hoarder
okay and she's 60 67 she has a 700
square foot apartment
small two-bedroom apartment and she's
just allowed it to become a disaster
zone
and uh her apartment complex is
threatening to kick her out
and she needs help i i want to help her
i love my mom you know she's not perfect
she's made a lot of mistakes but she's
loved me her my whole life and i want to
help her i want to help her clean it out
and i want to help her with tools so it
doesn't happen again and i want to help
her get therapy and i just
i really just don't know how to approach
that i'll go about doing that
man i love you curtis um thanks for
calling thanks for loving your mom man
and hoarding is embarrassing and it's
gross and it's hard and you're doing a
brave thing leaning into that man
and i'm grateful for you dude so um
when did this kick off often hoarding
behaviors start early in somebody's life
you can trace it back but sometimes they
just
something happens there's a death in the
family there is
there is some behavior that just flips a
switch and then things pile up
like really well so
her her parents were hoarders my
grandparents okay
and so she kind of grew up in a home
like that and you know she grew up broke
her dad couldn't hold on a job
you know they she didn't know you know
where money was going to come from
yeah if they were going to be able to
buy groceries and clothes and so forth
so she kind of grew up in that
environment where her her
parents had that that scarcity mindset
and so they just
accumulated everything because they
didn't know where you know if they were
going to be able to buy something in the
future and so that was that's kind of
like a script that was built into her
kind of like her subconscious i guess
but
it started for her maybe maybe
maybe 10 years ago
probably when she really started started
doing it herself
and what does it look like is it
newspapers and magazines and
and old food or is it a trink a specific
type of
collection that's gotten out of control
or pets what what does it look like
paint a picture for me yeah yeah so it's
the magazines it's old food
she she's a very avid crocheter so she
has
mountains of yarn okay and i i'm not
embellishing
no i know yarn that goes to the ceiling
yeah
um in just
just old mail okay so if you go to her
house
walk me through if you knocked on her
door today and you had a buddy with you
and y'all were wearing gloves and you
said mom we're cleaning up today
what would happen she probably won't let
us in
okay she would say get out this is my
house right
okay what is she protecting herself from
she's embarrassed okay she's she's
ashamed of what's going on she doesn't
want people to judge her
yep and that that shame leads to
more cover-up behavior which leads to
more loneliness which leads to more
cover-up behavior and so it goes right
right yeah so before i before i kind of
walk through what you can do
are you experiencing this no
not at all so you have no no hoarding
tendencies no hanging onto things or no
sentimental that you feels maybe a
little bit high a little bit a little
bit on the on the high end
no complete completely opposite you're a
minimalist right you live in a
yeah there's nothing on the walls
well my wife takes care of the walls but
i i try to have as
little as possible okay and i think i
think too because i grew up seeing my
grandparents in their house and so i saw
just how how horrible the life that is
and um
i just don't i just don't want that
happen to me yeah
okay so um you know this the
the hoarding is actually can be
considered a disorder you all know how
much
i disdain the the dsm but it's just the
excessive accumulation of objects that
lead to a mess and there's really not
a reason to have all the stuff right
there's not a reason to have
17 years of magazines and old food
and old dog food etc doesn't make it
doesn't make rational sense if you will
why these things are being kept
yeah and then number two there's an
unwillingness to part with these things
and number three is is where
where the kicker is is there's an
interference with healthy functioning
right there's an inability to have
people over that's like you talked about
that shame and then it just loops and
loops and loops and suddenly
you are trapped right so here's the
the tough news for you the
true hoarding right is this
nexus of impulsivity and it sounds like
a
really awful word but neurotic is the
word people's
people are are not functioning out of
their
rational mind right yeah and that
impulsivity is
very very hard to treat and so
i i this is just me i've always thought
there was an anxiety ocd addiction
component to hoarding that's just me
that's just how i read some of that
literature
i haven't actually done a big deep dive
into the literature but
it's this looping i need to solve this
problem
and then i'm just going to keep this and
then i get stuck on it and then when
someone tries to
help me with that then i grab even
tighter so this isn't like tv
these are really hard to treat and
you i don't know a situation unless
somebody just flips a switch somebody
can probably write into the show and let
me know of a situation i've never heard
of a situation that doesn't require
professional intervention
there are people there are mental health
professionals who do
this work exclusively this is what they
do
and they will work with people inside
and outside exposure therapy is
is the is the top line here and what
that is is you just have to slowly teach
somebody
how to experience throwing something
away similar to
if someone's got a phobia of snakes
they'll show you a picture of a snake
and the next time you come back they'll
show you a couple of pictures of snakes
right and slowly the goal is eventually
they're going to
show you an aquarium with a snake in it
you might go to the zoo together
eventually you're going to hold a snake
right and what you're doing is you're
teaching your body that this
isn't a threat right that this isn't
going to do the thing that your amygdala
is telling you or whatever part of your
brain is telling you is going to happen
and so exposure therapy some cognitive
behavior therapy that's that's
that's the way that works right that's
what you got to do but you got to get a
professional to do that
the thing you can do and it's going to
be mind-numbing and so hard
is to continue to let your mom know how
much you love her
and at the same time you've got to draw
really strong boundaries
right real strong boundaries meaning
you can't get drawn into that rabbit
hole right if you go
to her house while she's gone and you
just clean the whole thing up
you're going to implode a human being
right from the inside out
and so um
will she come out and visit you yeah
yeah okay
absolutely and does she have that those
tendencies when she's with you
or does she able when she gets out of
that environment is she able to
um is she able to come visit visit you
yeah she gets out of the environment
yeah she's different totally different
huh
so that's a great place to start would
she go see somebody does she know this
is a problem
i know she's seen a therapist in the
past for different things
um i think she would
to see a therapist for you know what
she's what's going on now
do you live in her area i don't know so
my mom lives about four hours away okay
all right um
some of these exposure therapies can be
done in intensives meaning
a four-hour session right with with a
therapist in a group
i wonder if and this may be a
conversation for you and your wife i
wonder if y'all could
have a family therapy session with your
wife
and you and your mom if your mom felt
that was a safe situation or if you have
brothers and sisters
and the idea being this not that there's
something wrong with mom
but that you ask mom tell your mom i
want
to do a better job of loving my mom and
i see you mom are struggling
and i don't have the tools to help in a
way that i want to
and so i'm going to go meet with a
counselor so i can learn some new tools
and i would love love for you to come
with me because then she can speak into
how do i love my mom better and that's
gonna help me
love my wife better that's gonna help me
love my kids better but mom would you
join me
and brothers and sisters so we can get
some more tools and that might
that might encourage her to come do one
of those four-hour intensives they're
expensive
and they're heavy but man they can be
healing when a family gets together that
way and remember this isn't hey mom i
want you to come down because you're
jacked up and we're gonna get we're
gonna get you healed now
you were talking about how you can get
some more tools so you can love her
better
and you want her to be a part of that
process man she's gonna feel
deep shame deep regret because she grew
up in this with her parents
right and she knows what it's like to be
embarrassed that nobody can come over
she knows what it's like to be trapped
and so lonely and you can't have anyone
come over and have coffee with you
and how you're always hiding this other
part of your life how you're never gonna
find any romantic partner she knows that
she doesn't need to be hit upside the
head with it what she does need is a
gentle introduction to somebody who is
safe who can begin
to walk alongside her in a healing
journey so brother i'm so grateful that
you are one of the guys who loves his
mom
enough to keep himself well keep his
family well
and to want her to just live
the last years of her life joyfully
thriving
and able to just simply move around her
apartment right things that most of us
take for granted every day
thank you so much for that call all
right as we wrap up today's show
um let's go here let's go with this one
i love this song and can i see this ass
is going to get me in trouble with the
cards and letters in the internets
there is the rare occasion the rare
occasion
when somebody does a cover of a song and
i think
that might be better and i recognize i
am i am
treading on super thin ice i'm gonna
fall through that ice and get trapped
under it i get that
but on the full moon fever album tom
petty
the great tom the great tp
wrote a song called free fallen
and then a couple of years ago i was
doing something
and i found myself humming along to a
song and i'm just gonna say it
john mayer's cover of free fallen
man he changed the key he changed the
swing of that song
he did it live just him and two other
dudes and acoustic guitars
man check out john mayer's cover of free
falling but but up for today's show
we're gonna go back to the og old tp tom
petty
free falling and it goes like this she's
a good girl
she loves her mama she loves jesus and
america too
and she's a good girl crazy about elvis
she loves horses and her boyfriend too
it's a long day living in reseda there's
a freeway running through the yard and
i'm a bad boy because i don't even miss
her
i'm a bad boy for breaking her heart and
i'm free
free falling and all the vampires
walking through the valley move west
down ventura boulevard all the bad boys
are standing in the shadows
and the good girls are home with broken
hearts and i want to glide down
over mulholland i want to write her name
in the sky
i'm going to free fall out into nothing
i'm going to leave this
world for a while i can't sing that i
was going to hit it but i missed it
i'm going to leave this world for a
while because i'm free
free falling right here on the dr john
dolone's show